nuevo tiroteo en luta de Estados Unidos
luego de que un joven armado de 23 años
irrumpiera en un banco de la ciudad de
Luffy en el estado de Kentucky las
autoridades investigan las razones que
habrían llevado al tirador a cometer el
delito pero confirmaron que se trata de
un antiguo trabajador de la entidad
bancaria que además estaba transmitiendo
en vivo
escuché un clic del rifle y la señora de
mi lado dijo qué diablos y luego
empezaron los disparos no pude verle la
cara pero era un rifle largo
estaba entrando al trabajo y escuché lo
que parecían disparos luego había dos
oficiales de policía y me dijeron que
corriera Así que salí corriendo la
policía local informó que el agresor
murió dentro del banco mediante un
intercambio de disparos también
agregaron que respondieron a la
emergencia en tan solo tres minutos vía
Twitter el presidente Joe biden condenó
el tiroteo masivo y criticó a los
republicanos por no lograr consensos
para regular las leyes de armas en el
país por su parte el gobernador del
estado realizó una rueda de prensa
visiblemente afectado luego de contar
que algunas de las víctimas eran
cercanas a él
esto es horrible
tengo un amigo muy cercano que no
sobrevivió hoy tengo otro que tampoco lo
logró y uno que está en el hospital
Espero que se salve entonces pido sus
oraciones para que lo logre según la
organización Gang violentowershift la
cual sigue la violencia Armada en
Estados Unidos en lo que va del 2023 se
han registrado más de 10.500 incidentes
con armas de fuego incluyendo tiroteos
masivos y suicidios